okay four people joining this some a
live stream we are in the late stages of
documenting our wonderful new synthetic
geometry capabilities for version 12 and
where will we at so far um we started
from the synthetic geometry guide page
is that correct
yeah and how much of that had we already
gone through I think the synthetic
geometry guide page was satisfactory my
last time okay okay oh yeah you know
this was pretty decent okay um okay okay
so what do we go to next have we done
the the Knitting of these functions to
each other only some of them okay no
look there's more about sort of missing
here okay so um okay geometric can't be
okay so let's just go down this list
here um so I think what we want to do
here we just open up all of these
by the way my um uh I was peeling here
my this thing that causes the the wrong
I mean that's basic geometric regions
okay to metric it would be really useful
if you'd be able to give me links which
would actually open these things I'll do
that in the future you know is it do we
know how to oh that's that page that
this is geometric special region so this
has not been renamed that page has not
been renamed okay what has derived
regions by the way do we have Charles
here or anybody from the the
computational geometry group
because we're gonna need them Charles is
on the invite list okay can somebody
please get Charles it varies here okay
so what we're going to be asking here is
how does this have to get knitted into
the UM the existing geometric
computation stuff great hold on let's
keep going here we'd already looked at
the plane geometry guide page as I
recall yeah I know where you looked at
it I don't know if we finished it man
just was somebody paying attention or
taking notes here what do we do we just
not do that because this time I'm kind
of please make sure somebody who is
cracking notes about what's happening
here I'll take notes okay okay because I
sort of clerical work of opening these
things is a little bit of a silly thing
for us to be doing um
all right I now have all these pages
open so again go down okay geometric
computation um okay so did we put stuff
in there
yes we did synthetic geometry is in
there okay so let's go back to the page
synthetic geometry and we want to say
more about geometric computation clearly
a worthwhile thing to point to
you
okay so this one is done right yes okay
and um okay let's go look at plain
geometry next so I believe we had redone
this before yeah we'd redone that again
yeah I'm not sure whether we need these
things which are clean not to plain
geometry well a little odd that we have
those there and what's general geometry
why do we even have this on this page
house can you speak to that please
Charles are you here yes I'm here I mean
this page is news to me I call this page
no you you wrote this page didn't you
who wrote this page I mean the initial
page Bobbitt for sure white we have that
page all right so didn't show matrix
reasoning was added I guess this was
probably a pretty old page we kept there
what are you talking about
I'm sorry I mean there's a set of new
fonts on when new pages we added when we
released the show-me tree framework and
then it was you know some which geometry
framework in version 10 when we did the
whole show met with a new region prior
to version 10 we had all pages like
planar geometry was you know listing all
due to the coffee primitive I believe
okay we've got a page about angles and
polar coordinates this does not appear
to have um our new angle stuff okay
where should that be on this page okay
so what we've got here we've got all
these angle bisectors we've also got
where is the thing where we compute
plane angles where is that here so your
measurements okay so somewhere here um
okay so I think we want to say the right
below angle vector I don't think so I
think it should be but oh no that's
create a vector at a specified angle
right that's different from vector angle
ah okay
okay so is it computing or measuring
angle specifying angles computing angles
okay so what we have there is for
computing angles we have now wise vector
angle not there okay vector angle will
be the most minimal one right isn't that
correct
yeah angle between vectors and vector
angle isn't in synthetic geometry
because doesn't really make sense there
right um I actually have support for it
oh you mean as I said you mean them to
paid sorry yeah okay um okay so planar
angle polygon angle those are the two
other ones the oh and also we couldn't
have died he drew angle all right it
should be died Daryl angle sorry down
girls which are the base okay so do we
need to list okay so when we say those
two probably want to get listed exactly
in this form planar angle defined by
three points is that right so how we
should say it here hey can you stop
clicking area please whoever's doing
that um is that the right thing to do
that think so
and then then can we just listing us in
a single line the dihedral angle and
polyhedra an angle does that make sense
is that okay or do we have to say them
explicitly what what do you think
feedback please well I mean since this
is kind of the main G page of angles I
think we should probably list them
explicitly okay
okay what does polyhedron angle and what
is dihedral angle so that our angle
complete angle between two planes right
3d yeah okay
angle between line what is that one
angle and Jack's angle polyhedron
well that's they see not really basic
right right because you have also on the
edge set motor so to say that again what
what should it be
so I'm just trying to touch back the
page report so that computer vertex on
edge angle so what should it be vertex
and edge angles yes okay so now we need
to have um let's see synthetic geometry
what you
constructions actually yep and there we
need to have angle bisector
I think angle bisector is the only one
okay well I think we also want to say
geometric um assertion an angle bisector
so let's just put in that single line
here and then why do you metric
assertion well I'm trying to think about
things which are doesn't it have other
stuff with angles what's the other
triangle construct does I see okay and
this wants to point to the synthetic
geometry shouldn't we have angle pad
here too we do to higher up on the page
okay
okay I'm not sure that page is
completely done you guys should look at
that some more please make the note of
that
[Music]
and let's point that to okay uh
we were looking at there that was angles
and polar coordinates which was pointed
to from so do we believe plane geometry
is finished now as well
yes I think that's done out
okay let's go on to
this geometric okay I'm gonna close that
page I will so pull a coordinates close
that page okay now um geometric
properties and measures so I think your
initial opinion was that nothing of our
is musical on this page is that final
yeah I'm by the way yes the comma is not
correct and fixed the comma please
um did you get that
yes
you
okay
you
okay so this is geometric properties and
measures done what about all this all
the stuff of triangles triangle
yeah we have that that triangle Center
we have this
you
this should be fine okay that one is
done okay
geometric special regions that's
otherwise known as geometrical okay why
was that
it's got the wrong name that's something
else that should get fixed okay
you got that yeah okay
you
you
you
okay so this page what should we add
here Charles um I don't think there is
any consult so we should add here maybe
circle to which I will add lit on small
when we add it now we're aware of the
circles here okay there we go so why
don't we just say circle defined by
three points is that right
makes sense yes three or more points you
can just copy the description from the
synthetic geometry back page I think
it's easier to tighten it um okay well
there we have circle through specified
points I don't know why that came out as
a table plus without the red thing
something else to check ok so there's
nothing else on this page that needs to
be there I mean even all these things
like bisectors and so on I don't
understand why you don't have those in
here right why aren't those why isn't
there a list of those things here I made
it clear in the Knitting notebook of
things I think should be added because
that page have the basic geometric
primitive which satisfies they don't you
okay well so should these I mean isn't a
midpoint a midpoint is a point isn't it
yeah it is an operation isn't is like we
don't put rage on sound wait in this
page well so as SAS triangle as an
operation is a constructor right so the
angle bisector then I'm
it's a fine line right you you can fill
the page with you know all the stuff you
want alright let's just point this page
to the synthetic geometry page so should
we point it should we put synthetic
geometry here or ok can we consider this
page done I think so ok geometric
solvers
you
okay we just we already have something
here this seems reasonable that page is
done I wish
Cabella notes last I'm sorry this is not
some okay derive regions
so I don't think anything should go on
here just want to get a confirmation
event yeah let's put geometric
constructions as a link here
you
you
okay all right let us go look at
synthetic Joe okay so that one is now
done as well okay so let's go now look
at the synthetic geometry functions and
check whether they have links correctly
the other functions that um sounds good
okay so random instance
fine
now we've gone through these individual
pages right
some of them that's not good enough
that's not good enough we need to know
specifically which pages have we gone
through which pages do we still have to
go through yeah I don't know because we
weren't jumping around so much oh okay
you guys need to do this work I'm not
gonna do this work okay you need to go
through and figure out if necessary go
look at the actual you know creation
times four pages and so on go figure out
which pages we still need to look at
okay okay
you
I don't think we've looked at this page
I think we have oh gosh
is Michael here by the way no no he's
traveling did we who agreed to schedule
this meeting when Michael wasn't here we
tried to have it earlier in the week but
you were busy and then yesterday morning
we couldn't be on short notice we
couldn't find Ian so he's I think he's
Michael will be available when did you
say James Thursday Friday and Monday and
then he's off to Thanksgiving yeah
Thursday Friday Monday okay is Alex here
okay so so what I'm gonna need from you
guys and this will end up having to be
probably I don't know how to fit this in
um you guys just need to do an analysis
which pages have been looked at in which
of not because I don't know okay all
right oh no this is no good
come on
um I don't think this is going to go
well here I mean you're basically
telling me what you have no idea what
we've looked at what we haven't looked
at did we redo this page or not you
don't know anybody got any idea we did
not yeah I don't think we did okay so
that's a no we didn't we did this page
do we do this
no we obviously haven't done this page
have we I'm not exactly happy here in
case you can't tell this is not how this
should work do we not have any project
manager involved with this reading at
yeah that's not supposed to be the way
these meetings work well Carla I'm a
project manager but I'm not the project
manager of this particular project right
Alex is Brett on Carla for this meeting
but
well there aren't too many of these I
guess I can do this work sigh okay we're
gonna go through these I believe I have
now opened every page that okay could
you look at this list please and tell me
if there are any pages that are
functions that you guys have created
that are not on here besides random
instance and fine geometric conjectures
okay all right we're gonna go through
every one of these sigh all right
midpoint of a line that's start with
that okay exactly why this doesn't point
to line could you please put yourself on
mute if you've got a bunch of background
noise it's the midpoint of the line
segment connecting the points p1 and p2
okay how are the points specified
they can be explicit coordinate pairs or
they can be things with the head point
we also this also works for a lot of
line slash multi-line I think you wanted
so so what does it do in the case of a
line with multiple points in it it finds
the it do what should I just try it yeah
so first of all you're telling me if I
say this for example right
I assume that's the first example
whatever yeah close enough right so if
you if the inputs are coordinates and at
points or return coordinates
okay
what are you telling me if I put in a
third point here no what are you telling
me if you put in something with headline
you're right oh okay okay so this is
incorrect then right so what happens if
I put it aligned with many points in it
as long as the line does not intersect
itself it should what does it mean to
have a midpoint of a line that isn't
straight it it takes the arc link and it
finds the point on the line such okay I
get it I get it I get it I get it again
okay okay okay so this is in fact not
correctly documented all right the
geometry team said that that should not
be documented until we're able to take
midpoints of any one dimensional region
well let's just say for a line here okay
Charles do you want to comment on this
well it depend of happy to comment it
right so I mean as long as we see that
the line have to be explicit head line
that's fine it is an arbitrary line
that's not possible
okay okay
could you please put yourself on mute
well as making that that background
noise um
okay so first of all here this certainly
should be
[Music]
I guess it should point to mean but it
should also point to point online
presumably
okay all right in midpoint of p1p2 the
piece of i/o it do we say it works in
any number of dimensions
they should it it does the piece of I
can be lists of coordinates
or explicit point objects um
you
they can also be symbols but we don't do
anything in that case that's just how we
use it in geometric scene okay so that's
another thing that has to be in the
documentation here no it actually in it
if I think it if they're symbols oh I
see I see sorry so sorry I did the
actual point being symbols not the
coordinates being so bossy
um midpoint the result from midpoint
midpoint gives a result gives its result
in the same form gosh
if the pie are lists of coordinates
midpoint gives a list of coordinates as
the result gives a list of coordinates
as a result of the pie and point objects
it gives a point object
you
okay midpoint of line of
P 1 P 2 dot dot dot gives the midpoint
gives the point on the line that is the
same distance the same hot distance
right a sense their distance along the
line or along the multi line same
distance from each end of the line right
okay okay now we can say midpoint can be
used symbolically
used with symbolic points unless you
have another wording for this in
geometric scene is that right that's
correct that sounds good so we're gonna
have to replicate that in other places
okay so here mean oh boy
mean has an awful lot of stuff
next point we already put my point on
that page okay point
Wow point doesn't get very much
that's really weird the point has
several so should midpoint beam be on
here shouldn't other Scot be on here as
well um is yeah no I mean is you're
serious up to date I don't know it
should have been updated today did you
change that today Charles I think so I
did some knitting this morning but I can
update it I can get it because I'm sure
I put hand on point on order stuff in
point do you want me the update or not I
can't fix that okay so you'll put other
stuff in there as well
yes okay all right midpoint is done then
okay next let's see what should we do
next how about we do perpendicular
bisector
seems rather straightforward
but that's not correct it can also have
a line in it right
correct let me check don't we want to
point these things including midpoint at
also at geometric scene I think we do
okay so it does work for a wine okay you
didn't document it that way
perpendicular bisector what is it doing
in more than two dimensions does it work
now only two dimensions okay so that
should be impossible issues please hear
all right
um okay so you're saying there's another
case here and what does it do with a
multi-line does it work with a
multi-line or not it does that okay what
is it
okay so does it rid would it return an
infinite line object even in this case
it's equivalent okay
okay do we need to have the jazz about
points that we've also put a midpoint
here
I don't think so why doesn't this have
the same behavior doesn't it have those
always returns an infinite line ah so it
allows different inputs but it still
returns the infinite line so okay great
okay angle bisector
you
you
you
by the way we had some comments on the
livestream had enough people have
survived watching us do this horrifying
stuff but Tim summers us Brian is asking
what's the schedule for updating the
elementary introduction to often
language new functionality in version 12
you know I haven't even started looking
at that good point I should do it um
sander is asking can we finally get 3d
Voronoi using the new polyhedron
functionality Charles maybe you'd like
to comment on that no Claude the next
widdy's okay
what the speck
you
okay so
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you this of them is a mistake
here in this
startup and poppin
Dacula bisector of p1p2 the piece of I
can either be lists of coordinates
right
and say in 2d
I'm not gonna comment on that
I consider just a bug that doesn't work
in more than 30
you
as it is it a bug that's going to be
fixed not sure how it's a bug
well Charles said only do it 40 does it
not mean anything beyond 2d you see what
you mean because you can be anywhere
around the line right right in other
words the put them to kill a bisector it
could be a plane it could be a hyper
hyper plane then let's say this for now
but I agree that I don't understand why
we wouldn't want to do that eventually
for general you know to make the plan to
make the plane basically the
perpendicular bisector of a line in 3d
is a plane we can plan on that in the
future seems like that's the right thing
to do I think I actually have the code
for it somewhere but Charles is there a
mood that's not what I worry about it
today yeah I make Charles is there any
reason we wouldn't want to do this no
it's just all the generalization on the
implication of what we we need to return
we needed to do our homework which was
not done for the n dimension that Y just
asked to stick with the 2d
okay can either be list of coordinates
or explicit point objects right yep
following by sector types
you
moment we have to say what the default
is what's the default the interior area
okay I have that in properties and
relations but no no that's not good
enough you have to say it here
so should we say head there's the
internal bisector
all right say the bisector of the
interior angle that P
you
okay
you
you
okay
you
let's just check that this points back
to angle bisector
oh gosh no it doesn't
okay
think plainer angles should point to
geometric scene also do you agree yes
okay
that's then those okay let's keep going
here okay so now we've got circle
through
you
you
you
okay what does it do if there isn't a
circle it should return on evaluated
okay with a message so so cool through
gives
and explicit gives when possible gives
when possible and explicit circle object
um if there is no way to satisfy to
satisfy the constraints defined by
circle through by a particular circle
through
you
you
now what about symbolic is this normally
going to give symbolic values and I
assume circle through only works and
into D right right now it only works in
geometric scene I mean right now what
are you talking about surely it just
truly it does what I just said it does
when possible gives a circle object
right it does do that doesn't it oh oh
for goodness sake come on guys what does
it do in that case when Thunder
determined okay let's say what are you
doing here what why isn't that returning
something come on guys okay you need to
make that work Charles are you still
planning and implementing that or do you
need to take it so let's take several
weeks okay okay so that's example number
one here should be that um let's see
you
okay now we got to say something about
overdetermined cases right
and what about precision in the
overdetermined case am i making sense
you understand what I'm asking all right
the question for Charles
I'm not understand what you mean
well if it's over determined and by the
way where should I put circle through
and circumspection go right after before
line yeah okay I'm asking if you give
these points and they are on a circle
but for some numerical precision what do
you do what is where we should probably
I just see this on the machine tolerance
or the default device okay what else
should be in this documentation here
you
by the way I mean they're a bunch of
things like circle and so on that
probably should have this some can be
used with symbolic points in a blah blah
all are that's okay
lost note presumably for a bunch of
those things please make sure Michael
sees those so you can check those
okay all right okay
alright next we have here I believe the
triangle functions is that right so
triangles Center triangle construct
triangle measurement okay so apparently
triangle Center we had not for some
strange reason um txt future eyes doe K
so you're not updating to the most
updated versions triangle Center for
some reason o sake well I think you guys
really messed up here because ok well I
will I will quit everything here okay
I'll go ahead and quit everything it's
only affecting triangle Center it looks
like so when I do what I'm about to do I
will club at anything that you put in
there in these pages today okay any page
that I modified will get clobbered
you
let's hope there wasn't too much
I had stuff there
um Karla you probably need to take up
with Rocha why this update didn't happen
and Alex probably should be I mean okay
so arguably I just made the mistake of
not updating at the beginning of this
meeting which normally I would do um
I think we started this meeting so late
I didn't think to do it
okay let's take a look now where's point
oh we didn't put point in here because
it isn't needed okay so you're saying
triangle Center you claimed oh sorry
that's revision one point two and we're
currently on one point twenty something
well you've made a mistake because I
just updated this so unless I clobbered
what you had so you better go look and
see what I call of what you have this is
a recurring issue just a triangle Center
and I think it's only on your machine
what are you talking about if I go to
cbs.com
i see the newer versions the newer
version of that is already in builds
well I just updated this so I don't know
what's going on um why don't you email
with your version to me right now all
right
I don't know how well this is gonna work
but I can try doing something here gosh
this is really a mess guys I'm sorry
this is really not a good good setup
it doesn't consist of defined by the
hypotheses
you
you
did you send this to me I don't have it
work on it
okay listen we're gonna run out of time
here so you guys need to reschedule this
Alex please figure out when this can be
scheduled it may have to be in an
evening I'm afraid I'm not very happy
about because I'm trying to work on some
other stuff it's just int it or Alex you
might see if you can get this in at 4:30
p.m. is Alex here
you
all right so I have no idea what's going
on here are the examples also changed
and things yeah
all right I'll try doing something which
I'm not keen on doing
if I thought that beeped is really
really not a good sign
the fact that it's got two of those
lines I think you're gonna have to ask
ya see that you you've got a line there
that says this was created in October
and I've got a line here that says it
was created in January am i making sense
you know something got goofed up
somewhere here and why is it beeping
that's really really a bad sign
you try to delete the sellers not
palatable
okay Carlo I think this is for you
you should get Brian let me see what
happens if I try pushing those well if I
try pushing these I ought to be out of
them
you
okay so um we got to remember for next
time the triangle functions and all the
ones up here or what we have to do right
yes but let me see what happens if I try
pushing that page back
you
see whether it save something
you
you
that is the weirdest thing okay
something is very very wrong here with
that page okay because if you look at
this this here
you loved the way that was a spelling
mistake in the script kamae ting um the
collar if you could ask Roger to fix
that it would be really good okay anyway
look at this
I'm suspicious about that
but that has has messed something up
okay so you need to get Brian today to
go look at this okay between Brian and
Roger they need to go sort this out okay
make sense all right we should wrap this
meeting okay not not our best needs to
be continued let's try and make sure we
have we get through the rest of it I'm
lovely functionality though wonderful
functionality all right talk to you soon